that uh that last fight with with tito
the one that that when we were in peru
you told me you were thinking about
like it was it was tough man and i know
that like the world responded to it and
uh
you know like they they viewed it as
sort of sort of a a bummer
and
i from my perspective
i uh
i thought was [ __ ] you know like here's
chuck he's a fighter he [ __ ] misses
it like it's in him like it's just like
i i just felt like
you know i i understand i understood why
you wanted to do it and i thought it was
[ __ ] great that you went for it yeah
and as i
obviously i wish i was healthier and i
wish i you know i wish i performed
better but other than that hey i went
out and did my thing i like you know
it's what it is yeah it it right
something lose something is i mean
i mean
i didn't do any i didn't do anything i
went out and did the best i could i mean
dude
as far as your legacy goes i mean it
doesn't [ __ ] change [ __ ] about the
fact that you're the [ __ ] iceman
chuck liddell dude right yeah i don't i
don't feel that at all and you're uh
you're chucking tito 30 for 30 was
fantastic
oh yeah that was awesome it really was
they did a really good job with that um
having it uh
you know getting it you know for getting
a lot of issues and a lot of a lot of
history and a lot of stuff i thought
they covered it pretty well yeah dave
for sure
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]